all right another prime time smackdown
i'm with famous
streamer eric rosen but eric tell the
story of what happened the last time we
played bullet
so i don't entirely remember um it's
kind of suppressed in my memory but i
know
that we played at some point like two or
three years ago
one is i didn't lose all the games but
you didn't lose all the games i think
you
won like a game or two more okay
um so i need revenge those are the days
yeah
all right but we're gonna play best of
five bullet jokes aside and this is
gonna be a lot of fun hopefully
everyone enjoys it and uh here we go
okay so best of five is first to three
correct
first of three points okay yep good to
know so here we go
rematch sent and uh we're off to see the
wizard
um you're you're a you're like a
you you play real openings kind of guy
right did you prepare for me
did i dude the last time i prepared for
anything was because i prepared for you
did you
oh my god okay crap all right but maybe
that'll help backfire
a little bit you know um why did i take
with the pawn
queen trade probably would have been
better oh my god that doesn't win the
bishop
he doesn't win a bishop and don't trick
me like that don't scare me like that
i thought it won a bishop i forgot your
night was defending ooh what is this
move
i know look at that i'm i'm getting
dirty on you
okay wait don't hurt me
wait this has got to be good for me hold
on what am i going to do here
you can think for another 30 seconds
you're into that
really into that um kind of i don't even
know what i'm doing anymore
um i sacked the exchange which was
probably a bogus idea
story of my life
um is this where we like say how's it
going in general like
i guess what's up twitch chat future
twitch
don't hurt me i i want to though that's
the thing
is that
i feel like i have to play faster if i'm
ever going to win more chess games in my
life
and so i'm trying to do that right now
okay
um
ah i know i know what you're thinking
your bishop's so annoying
i know you're thinking you're too young
to die oh
why did i do that no there we go
no you're like oh there's the inevitable
wonder by danny
oh no i really appreciate the generosity
okay it was such a good game for me you
were
you were devouring me and then somehow
you just let me crawl away
i admit i i forgot that on e2 you can
take my bishop so okay
yeah you know okay you you you accepted
my invitation i was trying to be
hospitable you know now i realize
you're probably gonna sweep me if i
don't wake up so here we go
okay um what normally see
why would you ever prepare for me dude
preparing for me is like
i look i had to look up your openings
because i i just want to know what you
play against stafford gambit
oh wait a second i know that this is
losing for me if i don't do the right
thing
really you didn't watch all of them
though you didn't watch the the one
about this sign
oh what is this move you dirty dog i
know how i'm supposed to beat the
stafford gambit i saw half food do it on
pogchamps
yeah no she was actually really well
prepared well prepared
freaking robert house darn that guy hate
that guy
i hate that guy he's mean sometimes but
he's also knowledgeable
wait what are you gonna do next i just
want to do things
you're gonna crush me yeah wait that's
part of your plan
um it was part of your plan
[Music]
um it is still part of your plan i mean
i guess i gotta go here right
i've got no that's a nice king it's a
nice active
oh my queen's almost trapped super
active king right
that guy's eight year old it's your most
active piece
uh that that was actually really painful
and hurtful that's what you got for
trying to hurt me the first game
oh my god why did you have to play the
stafford gambit you know i'm not ready
you are not oh it's double checkmate
oh but not yet wait where's my meat you
almost did it just do it just
play queen b5 like you almost did
there we go okay i played queen b5 i
hope you're happy
i could not believe you just beat me
with the staff for gambit that was
insulting
and i have to back up and to remember
what was supposed to be doing well thank
you
i i'm gonna play it again so you better
be prepared oh but if i win the next
game
the match is over okay i'm ready
okay i need to pay more attention to
your videos when i watch them
um if you watch my london videos
but yeah um
you're so tricky thank you become so
tricky know what happened to that
sweet little kid i was you know playing
ping-pong with in chicago
yeah we played ping-pong like a decade
ago
right people know what a badass you are
a table tennis by the way
but you you beat you beat me i think or
no i beat you but it was close
i'm pretty good too but you beat me um
yeah i was in uh a grand master's base
it was in uh mezzan's basement
yeah yeah and well so was there randomly
what wesley so was there it was like the
whole
old uh webster team
how do i meet you what is going on here
i would prefer if you didn't make me is
that okay
um that would be i could flag you
maybe in my schedule
i could fork you
my schedule is better
for me if you don't make me
man you like to be active with your king
dude it's my thing
i've become super into it
do i play g6 yes uh
no your bishop stays put for quite some
time
yeah my pawn how about me
oh oh my time
oh no what are you doing
i'm pre-moving
oh tactics oh it doesn't work though
or does it
ah my queen
yeah oh good game
oh that was nerve-wracking
nasty oh my god i forgot that we were
playing bullet
almost greater than you're coming into
this match you realize that really
oh yeah um i guess does that make me a
farmer
i mean you are from the midwest so just
embrace it yeah i guess so
you guys we could have named your your
protest league team the midwest um
farmers um oh that would have been
is it too late it's been a bad name
actually yeah the farmers
double meaning can we apply for a name
change maybe we can
yeah just like committee i can't believe
you just swept me i
especially that last game what was the
final what was the final deal on the
clock
i feel like a groom dude i've gotten old
man my nerves
you start blitzing me and there's a part
of me inside that's like
you're too slow to do this and that's
what keeps that's what keeps hitting in
my
head so i i prepared a little bit for
you so i i
was expecting basically all the openings
that we played but
the last game was close can we end the
primetime video and you just give me a
lesson on the stafford now
yeah yeah um how do i can you invite me
to analysis board
yeah let's do that okay yeah this video
is over everybody thanks for watching
we're gonna go do a lesson with eric
rosen on the staff
sounds good
all right uh penny we're done um yeah
all right so but seriously what what am
i supposed to do against the staff again
but hold up so
i don't know if you saw nerdsy's video
but he did like a
half hour breakdown of like the whole
refutation
which is really i guess i need to if i'm
gonna start playing you i just so it
it basically shows the line that hafu
played but super in depth
so you're following the board right yes
so it's takes takes and then i am
supposed to play d3 right
um there's a few options but d3 is
probably the most solid
and then what happened oh this is what
hafu played yeah
and then bishop c5 i was supposed to
play c3 so
actually no um c3 is still objectively
fine
but it's weird because c3 and h3 are
like kind of the safe looking moves
but they both run into so bishop e2 is
the best move
because c3 and h3 both run into bishop
takes f2
um so bishop e2 it prevents uh or it
basically discourages knight g4
it prevents any bishop takes off two
ideas right
i would still have some tricks here
right
this is one possibility yes okay
and you can get away like i can show
after takes
queen here you can get away with being
up a pawn
uh you have queen f3
takes in queen g3 and this is what
nereditzky shows
got it um but i actually have i secret
preparation beyond this
okay that's that's what we need to do is
we need to have a follow-up rematch
yeah and uh
and then there's another trap uh there's
h5 here
which actually david pakman played
against hafu
and then the cool trap is after let's
say castling
knight here h3 black has a really nice
move queen d6
and if this is bullet black is um i mean
black will win like ninety percent
i saw you win some games on leach s on
this line
yeah so i have a video it just passed a
million views where i keep beating
people with this uh
this exact trap like even title players
fall into like g3 queen takes g3
yeah yeah so hilarious um so it's
necessary for white after h5
to then play c3 and this is what hafu
played and then
it's good for white got it
okay all right well you just made me a
better chess player
big surprise so every loss is a lesson
hopefully every loss is a lesson you're
never losing
you're not you're never let's wait for
levy to join
you're never losing if you're learning
exactly yeah